un père jean tu es très énervé on va
revoir ton tweet viols et agressions
sexuelles sur mineures le chanteur
jean-luc lahaye passe en garde à vue
franchement on n'en peut plus de cette
justice et pourquoi pas un serial killer
je suis trop triste notre pays est
devenu une parodie de démocratie alors
ton tweet a énormément
choqué est ce que vous comprenez le
tweet voilà le coup de gueule de pierre
jean pierre lançon contre la garde à vue
de jean luc lahaye pourquoi tu as fait
ce trip c'est alors il aya que guillaume
la quille bon alors oui tu sais moi
j'aime beaucoup jean luc oui j'ai eu un
repas revenir sur mes histoires m'ont
face à fait car avec un stock quelques
temps j'ai eu quand même quelques petits
soucis et j'ai quelques amis dont jean
luc qui ont toujours été là d'accord
donc çà çà çà revient ce qu'on disait
jeudi à défendre ses amis
mdr car il ya le poids on peut défendre
ses amis gilles verdez s'ouvre répondait
déjà ça moi ce qui me gêne c'est la
parodie de démocratie là on n'est pas
dans l'amitié on est dans un jugement
sur l'évolution de la justice monsieur
là est présumé innocent est actuellement
en garde à vue il ya des charges qui
sont sérieuses on verra l'issue mais si
vous voulez la manière je trouve dont
vous bafouez l'honneur des victimes
présumées dont vous bradez toute cette
justice c'est hyper violent je reconnais
pas la france dans vos propos je suis
extrêmement choquée et en colère
je peux comprendre mais tu me connais je
suis quelqu'un de cash quand j'ai appris
ça il était assez tard et j'ai dit c'est
pas possible qu'est ce qu'ils ont encore
fait à jean-luc quoi mais
pardonnez moi mais
c'est une personnalité qui est mise en
garde à vue où il vient au bon sens mais
bien en garde à vue au programme je dors
pas
je suis mieux pour nous on a envie et ça
sera l'objet de la garde à vue c'est
qu'est ce qu'il lui a bien pu faire à
ces jeunes filles mais je vous rassure
c'est les paradigmes passe avec il a
déjà été condamné notre ami c'est oui
encore eux sont mineurs déjà avec cette
fameuse histoire oui oui oui et donc
tout ça ça donc 13 institutions moi je
crois mais je crois en la justice
attention à
ça ça fait beaucoup quoi là rien mais il
ya un moment par exemple on parle de
jean luc et on parle aussi dans
maintenant quelques mois aussi parler
d'intermittents marc morandini qui a eu
à peu près qui a été remis
oui mais ça doit être ça a été il allait
l'année dernière les juges ont dit qu'il
devait juger bon bah y'a un truc ya un
moment c'est tout il ya toujours
beaucoup de choses et moi ça me fait de
la peine d'avoir les choses mais c'est
pas le même sens et du tout c'est le
même sujet même sujet
par mail attendu que les filles on parle
sort les dents l'ucla hier le mais de
quoi parlez
vous mélangez tout l'axé
jeune fille en 2015 quels rapports ont
dit quelque chose elles ont retiré leur
plainte aujourd'hui elles viennent dire
on a retiré notre plainte parce qu'il ya
eu contrainte parce qu'on sert encore il
ya eu et subornation de témoin visait
pas en tout cas il y aurait eu
cybernation de témoin et c'est pour ça
que la justice enquête et c'est normal
que la justice enquête en se demandant
oui ou non ces jeunes filles il ya eu
subornation de témoin oui ou non et du
viol en prison oui ou non elles ont eu
peur et effectivement avec moi je ne
juge bon dans ces cas là ces ne jugez
pas on se tait mais moi c'est une
parodie démocratie alors c'est grotesque
choquant inaudible ce que vous dites en
fait d'accord cela dit mardi des mains
non mais ne riez pas sur ce plateau moi
j'ai rien du tout pas non non moi je
peux je ne parlais pas du tout cette
histoire je vous explique claire alors
bah oui c'était pas clair
suite
moi je suis venu ici pour dire qu' il ya
un moment il faut avant de juger il faut
savoir les choses moi j'avais à part un
bon parent de spectacles sable et
charles trenet et charles trenet c'était
un homme extraordinaire il a fait deux
mois de préventive de tôle parce qu'il
ya quelques années on a dit qu'il était
pédophile hockey et il en est sorti
totalement blanchi etc mais pendant
cinquante ans les 50 millions restaient
à vivre c'était toujours charles trenet
pédophiles charpennes et j'ai défendu
charles et encore aujourd'hui sur sa
tombe et c'est donc c'est simple je vous
fais pas je pense que beaucoup de gens
qui vous regardent la vous trouve
particulièrement indécent déjà parce que
j'aimerais rappeler qu'il ya déjà une
condamnation chantier qu'on parle quand
même d'une personne de 60 ans je pense
j'en ai parlé notoriété non monsieur sur
la notoriété des vidéos sexuelles et des
rapports sexuels avec joris en 1900 même
parler sans même parler de justice déjà
que ce soit votre ami ou pas il ya déjà
un moment où vous devez prendre position
mais il ya quand même quelque chose qui
me choque c'est que vous avez vous avez
le pouvoir de venir sur un plateau télé
pour aller prendre sa défense et vous le
défendez corps et âme parce que c'est
votre ami
mais est ce que vous pensez en victime
derrière un mur tout ya autre chose
c'est que c'est pas le premier jeu là
dans cette affaire et qu'à chaque fois
qu'il ya un violeur qu'une personne
connue elle est mêlée à quelque chose
comme ça parce que la moitié du show
business aléas mais avec il ya forcément
la moitié qui vient le défendre et vous
faites partie de tout un système qui
fait qu'à chaque fois que des victimes
veulent prendre la parole alors que là
on a des preuves jusqu'à +1 ils ont noté
la
direction et
enfin le jeu léché qui va déterminer ce
qu'il veut et mais il ya quand même une
affaire a commenté et moi je dis que la
présomption d'innocence souvent ça
bénéfices et plus aux personnes connues
qui derrière ensuite ont des amis qui
vient de les défendre que victime parce
que quand on regarde les faits on voit
qu'il ya quand même des choses très très
graves séquelles sur précieux play
couche celle des filles mineures
pierre-jean juste est ce qu est ce que
vous pensez quand vous twittez ça
peut-être aux victimes aux familles des
victimes six victimes présumées ou
est-ce que vous n'y croyez pas du tout
bien sûr même est ce que c'est vrai que
c'est quand même et tu le mets tu me
connais je suis toujours très cash après
je redescends et je le dis mais quand tu
as un ami quand un copain qui tape comme
ça sur le but que ayant gardé avec sa
fille avec après bien entendu que tu
penses à c'est à ces victimes et c'est
horrible tu sais j'ai suffisamment
d'amis qui ont eu des problèmes comme ça
donc je compatis totalement mais c'est
vrai que c'est sur le je suis impulsif
mais c'est d'être cash vous avez d'une
énorme pari est perdant quelque chose
je le jeu le jeu l'acceptent mais en
attendant quant à un copain qui est
comme ça et tu dis [ __ ] le mec il en
garde à vue
mais pourquoi tu étais à la limite c'est
l'allégeance à ma vie je les ai enlevés
la veille l'étape j'ai pas dormi de la
nuit j'ai eu du projet eut détruit je
dis [ __ ] merde le pauvre il est avec
sa fille
il est de l'e2c deux victimes présumées
bon je ne sais pas alors justement de
bramois la vraie question vos pauses os
et ils en pensent quoi votre frère oui
bah monfort il est là ces émissions se
demander si on trouvait ça normal de
défendre ses amis ben moi je trouve ça
normal et cette polémique elle montre
bien qu'on est en train de tout temps
mais la réplique
il a fait une connerie attendues au même
père jean dire qu'il a fait tendre et
sur le client tu penses à la hausse il
ya suspicion d'agression
viol sur mineure n'en a résulté pourquoi
maintenant ma vie on entraîne de
tribunal judiciaire et tribunal
médiatique c'est pas un juge qui parle
c'est son ami donc il a le droit d'être
de mauvaise foi il a droit de dire
n'importe quoi il défend son ami et
pardon c'est pas politiquement correct
ce que je vais dire mais les gens qui
ont commis des horreurs ils ont le droit
d'avoir les amis oui tout est moche les
serial killers en prison les gens qui
ont commis des choses atroces ils ont
des amis et jour parfois et privés sinon
ça veut dire quoi c'est dire que quand
on a commis quelque chose de très grave
on ne peut plus vivre en fait voler tuer
directement ces gens là je suis désolé
c'est comme ça on a le droit d'avoir des
amis et il a le droit de soutenir ses
amis et à la justice pour condamner les
actes et
non mais hélas la question est comment
est-ce qu'on ait choqué par ce tweet le
poème de pierre gensse et que son pire
ennemi c'est lui à chaque fois il fait
des plus malheureux des fois il ya
imposé excusez cette idée me la
rend compte que ça fait maintenant deux
ou trois ans était toujours dans des
dans des histoires de tweed de buzz de
bad buzz de correct a dit de photos que
tu fais est alors dit qu'on est en voilà
et c'est vrai que c'est on se dit soit
il fait exprès
les côtes vont tomber quoi
je ne fais pas que ça
que pour ça et
c'est dur de paix mais c'est dur de
t'aimer frais des trucs comme ça on n'a
pas assez contraignant défend toi moi je
suis vraiment moi j'ai de l'amitié tu as
raison quand on aime quelqu'un on y ont
peut être choquer au premier rail mais
tout n'a pas les termes que tu rappelles
le bi le fait pas très bon on n'est pas
dans ce tribunal
aussi pas parler comme ça tu vois là je
dirais que c'est un ami de cheryl je
suis rarement n'est pas d'accord avec
son genou il devrait agir a dit
géraldine faut pas non plus j'ai
toujours à dean l'a dit voilà le tweet
c'est vrai que je te le dis d'argent
voilà beaucoup mais voilà je twitte ciré
oui c'est des conneries dg heisinger
venir ce serait porteuse pour le dire à
lui dit on est armé pour dire que ça
j'en sais rien mais alors messieurs
quand je sais indécent de dire ça on est
pas moi je pense justement
il serait temps qui est du changement
vous avez vu le témoin d'avant vous
croyez qu'on est vraiment dans une
parodie démocratie vous pensez pas à
bâle âge-là bord en turquie c'est quand
même très
fiers genre qu'on vous dit il est en
quête du changement vous attendez les
élections d'avril bah je pense que comme
beaucoup de français on attend on attend
de voir qui va se passer oui je pense
vous avez déjà vous savez déjà pour qui
vous allez voter a pas du tout pas du
tout non pas du tout a pour le moment
non moi j'attends les programmes très
j'étais plutôt bas kron à un moment oui
mais aujourd'hui je ne sais pas je vais
attendre à voir